des camions ukrainien dans les rues de
kiev cerner applaudi par les habitants
symbole d'un peuple qui soutient son
armée pourtant face à l'attack russe le
président ukrainien volodimir hélène ce
qui semble aujourd'hui démunis en pleine
nuit il lance un appel à l'aide
internationale
nous sommes seuls à défendre notre
nation
qui est prêt à se battre avec nous
je ne vois personne
qui est prêt à donner à l'ukraine une
garantie pour rejoindre l'otan nat tout
le monde a peur
shibuya le président ukrainien affirme
être personnellement visé par vladimir
poutine
d'après les informations que nous avons
l'ennemi m'a désigné comme cible numéro
1 la famille est la cible numéro 2 ils
veulent détruire l'ukraine politiquement
en détruisant le chef de l'état
des rumeurs le disaient en fuite mais il
affirme être encore à kiev ce matin la
france se dit prête à lui porter secours
s'il est menacée je pense que la
sécurité du président des aînés ce qui
est un élément central de ce qui se
passe maintenant et nous sommes en
situation de pouvoir l'aider si
nécessaire mais il apporte qu'il tienne
sa place j'ai dessiné ses serres ça veut
dire quoi jean yves le drian nous
prendrons les dispositions qu'il
convient de prendre le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky ancien
humoriste élus en 2019 sans aucune
expérience politique s'est mué en chef
de guerre un rôle qu'il endosse pour
l'instant avec sang-froid
favorable au dialogue avec la russie
depuis toujours il maintient encore
cette position malgré la guerre déclarée
contre lui